if
your leader is a a dynamic
empathetic
vulnerable
teacher mentor chances are you have a
pretty good culture
but if you're if your leader is
and i hate to say this because i am one
an old white guy that has only learned
how to lead one way and that's
autocratic command and control
um boisterous
decisive
then chances are you don't have a really
good culture
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders and we're
going to be talking about doing good in
the workplace
meet mark babbitt president of word iq
and co-author of good comes first
employees of all generations desire and
deserve workplaces where they feel
respected and are validated for their
ideas efforts and contributions every
day as we're witnessing right now when a
company culture falls short of those
expectations top talent is cutting the
lifeline that has tethered them to their
old employers and old autocratic leaders
often feel afflicted with what we call
boomer male syndrome or bms
in record numbers good people are
leaving bad companies or at least bad
company cultures to retain and attract
top talent today's leaders must now work
with all stakeholders not just
shareholders to create an uncompromising
company culture where employees can
expect respect while helping drive
results in other words they must ensure
good comes first
[Applause]
mark babbitt welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you right now i'm doing
just fine thank you so where where are
you based right now you mentioned that
you're in in some room in in a different
location than what i perhaps would have
expected well i i i decided to raise my
family in the in the mountains so we're
up in colorado between denver and
colorado springs
uh enjoying the fall season
beautiful i love it okay so today we're
gonna dive deep into culture and culture
is something that you know we've been
hearing a lot in the these past few
years particularly in this past two
years as companies had to navigate some
difficult decisions regarding their
employees their their work life balance
the way that that companies are actually
working with employees
but it's but it seems like it's still a
big mystery as to you know what is what
is the relevance of culture in a company
setting when is the right time to work
on culture and how do you actually
measure
good culture and
on your shirt i read good comes first
which is the title of your new book and
and i'm really excited to be talking to
a culture expert
and having you know researched this and
studied this i'm excited to pick your
brain on what does it mean to build good
culture for employees and for companies
to thrive where good comes first so mark
tell me a little bit about yourself and
about good comes first i started my
professional career in the in the united
states military in the air force
and did what every military trained
engineer does when you get out of the
military you go to silicon valley
and applied the trade of engineering for
about a decade and when this just sucks
this is not who i'm supposed to be
and and immediately went into the
startup world and
and rested there for about 20 years
two very successful startups
one that should have been good but uh
but you know leadership and culture
played a major role
in this company that i came into uh
later
and and from that point i became
fascinated with leadership's impact on
culture
and
and it was funny to me that leadership
was always willing to spend money
and time and energy and entire teams
on things like employee engagement
and retention rates with hr
and success rates with attracting top
talent again with hr
and and
many other metrics
but they weren't willing to look
internally at themselves first as
leaders and specifically at their
company culture
and that struck me as odd because how
can you improve employee engagement and
all these other metrics
if your company culture sucks
and and so
especially
my my startup experiences were in the
career space
and we were sending people into a
workforce that was not at all satisfying
or fulfilling and
and so those two areas kind of collided
between my experience in the career
world and and and this
this uh continuous observation that
leaders didn't understand how they
impacted culture and that brought us to
where we are today what does it mean to
research culture can you can you help me
understand
what does that process even look like
from your perspective how do you go
about researching culture
so the first thing we do is we
we help our our clients and and
certainly in good comes first we we talk
about how to do this we actually help
them formalize their culture
um as you might have experienced michael
most cultures are accidental
they're they're not intentional at all
often they take the the form of
the strongest personality in the
leadership group the ceo the founder
of the president the executive director
and a non-profit
but it's not intentional
so
if
your leader is a dynamic
empathetic
vulnerable
teacher mentor yes are you have a pretty
good culture
but if you're if your leader is
and i hate to say this because i am one
an old white guy that has only learned
how to lead one way and that's
autocratic command and control
boisterous
decisive
then chances are you don't have a really
good culture because
our leaders
our fellow leaders in the c-suite our
bps our next level leaders our directors
and and eventually our middle managers
all
take on the personality of that
autocratic command and control
old white guy and uh not empathetic not
vulnerable not an active listener and
and so getting back to your question
finally michael we we measure because we
actually ask people
what how well do your leaders live up to
the values you know that that poster on
the wall the mission statement on the
wall how
how how how are we doing what's working
well and what's not
and and oftentimes
we learn that the the people that are
actually employed there they don't care
what the about us page says they don't
care what the careers page says they
don't care what that plaque on the wall
says
they
they have a much different version of
culture than the leaders do and this
disconnect is
easily measured
but unfortunately not many companies go
that route again we we we tend to focus
on the symptoms not the problem
right now
maybe before we dive deep deeper into
creating a good culture
what is the what are the side effects of
having bad culture can you share with me
a little bit of more tangible examples
of you know how where we've seen we've
had bad culture experiences and how that
has
impacted the company in a negative way
because
just like you know talking about
startups i'm trying to first formulate
the pain point that you know good comes
first comes to tackle so
pain points are are prolific pain points
are employee engagement
a pain point is
a retention and attraction of top talent
but but also real numbers are affected
productivity profits
we can't ask people to serve our
customers well
if we're not treating them well
so customer service
relationships are impacted
across the board
a a company culture can either
positively or negatively impact every
metric we measure
and
and i i'll tell you we're seeing it
right now
in
in in terms of people
voting with their feet we're people talk
we're talking about a labor shortage a
worldwide labor shortage
but the companies that have really good
cultures
they don't have labor shortages the
industries that have historically
treated their people well
don't have labor shortages
but if you look at hospitality
restaurants bars
where people are working for tips
they're they're they're literally just
grinding every night working for tips
and and our employers are not taking
care of them well they're having a huge
labor shortage
but michael you've probably seen this
the companies that are really good
companies and have amazing leadership
and really good cultures they have a
line out the door
of people who want to come work for them
because people are voting with their
feet they're not tolerating maybe
they've been there 10 12 15 years
now the pandemic comes along
and it's
we're not working from home and we have
this freedom and this autonomy and we've
gotten to decide when and where and how
our work gets done
and now those leaders are like going
well just forget forget the last 18
months forget all that freedom we gave
you
we're gonna suck you back into that old
culture that you that didn't fulfill you
at all well people go no i've
i've had a chance to re-evaluate what's
important to me i like being home with
my significant other my kids my my
four-legged kids my elderly parents my
extended family i i like seeing my kids
soccer games and i'm not going to go but
i'm not i'm not going to be on a train
in an hour and a half a day work 10
hours come home an hour and a half a day
and then just be angry
that i'm eating a cold dinner and i miss
my daughter's soccer game i'm not going
to do that anymore and and so they're
leaving they're right they're finding
companies
where that autonomy that freedom that
that culture
inspires them to do good work
right now
tell me about good comes first so
culture is critical bad culture is
you know is the detrimental to the the
way of a company either succeeding with
its product development or with its
hiring top talent word uh what what is
good comes first is the book what what
does it aim to achieve
so it aims to achieve
our our our goal is simple michael good
people
doing good work
in a good place to work and and i know
that sounds
ridiculously simple but in all the
research that we did in our client work
that's the common denominator
now in order for that to happen
we have to convince leaders that it's
not okay
just to focus on results
that that results alone are not going to
help you gain the results you want
so
we we introduced the idea of
making the showing of respect the
demonstration of respect to every person
in the company every stakeholder not
just shareholders
not just executives which is frankly
since the industrial age began how we've
kind of focused
right that's the results focus
but now how are we treating people how
are we asking people to treat each other
and so
in good comes first we're asking leaders
to say yes results are important if we
don't have good results we don't have a
company right we can't hire good people
but respect has to be on that same plane
and
and it really does come down to how
we treat each other do people feel
valued
respected
appreciated validated
and and once we accomplish that goal
well that's the key for for all the
companies we researched that's the key
when people feel good about the work
they do when they know their work really
matters
and they're helping drive results well
now we probably have a good company
culture can you share some case studies
where you've observed
significantly positive company culture
where a company and and the leadership
is upholding the values that you're just
mentioning now
of course and and
we mentioned several of them in the book
and and we were so happy as we were
doing the research
to learn how many leaders were so
focused on this respect issue
that it became the focal point of our
work and i'll give you my favorite
example
is an hr platform out of utah called
bamboo hr
and
bamboo hr historically
has treated their employees incredibly
well and my favorite example michael
is
they
they not only focus on personal and
professional growth which is huge in a
in a good counselor's culture they not
only focus on respect
but they focus intrinsically
systemically on employee wellness
and and
burnout
stress
is
not only a major indicator of a poor
company culture
but in a good company culture it's
something that the leaders deliberately
focus on and and they work hard to avoid
it and
and the way bamboo hr does this
among many other ways is they offer
their employees a paid paid vacation so
of course they paid them while they're
on vacation like everybody else does
but they also pay them to take vacation
they'll say here's wow 21 here's 2100
you
go go buy you and your partner a cruise
go take your kids to disney world do
something
this is our money
and and oh by the way
taking your paid time off not optional
it doesn't accrue
because if they
allow pto to accrue
that means in a in a backhanded way
they're actually
you know enforcing or or or um
tolerating burnout
no you're going to take this right this
is important to you the mental wellness
it's important to us because we need you
refreshed and engaged and so
we're not only going to make sure you
take that vacation but we're going to
give you money so you can do something
amazing and and that's just a
just a great example of a company
treating their people absolutely well
incredible incredible tell me a little
bit more about
being very intentional with creating
positive culture and what are some
actionable things that you know either
myself or my friends that may have
startups
what what what could we as as you know
upcoming leaders hopefully upcoming
leaders do
to
create better culture intentionally well
the key word is intentionally it's
it's taking a look back and this might
take an afternoon
it might take a facilitator in a room
to say okay what kind of company do we
want to be what are the three four five
values that are that we will not
compromise on
and
and if we do compromise on those
an example michael is integrity
integrity is a core value of just about
every company we've ever talked to ever
worked with
but then when the third company the
third quarter report is ready to come
out
we'll take shortcuts
we'll fudge the numbers we'll we'll move
things from column a to column b it's
we're not cheating we're not lying the
sec is not going to come after us
but
but we're
we're doing what we have to to make that
third quarter report look better right
well employees see that staff sees that
the accounting team sees that
when when the the sales figures come out
the sales team goes oh i didn't know we
did that well
you've you've just contradicted one of
your key
um values
and
and so right
that that's a big part of it and so
one define your values formalize your
values now and not just your values
but then pick three or four behaviors
that might indicate
whether you're living that value or not
i'll go back to the integrity
value
we have we have a client that says when
we measure that that value or or their
ability to serve as chief role model for
that value
we say does this leader keep their
promises
do they do what they say they're going
to do because that's kind of the
definition of integrity right and so
we actually provide feedback on that and
and and you don't need us to do that the
book lays out exactly how to do that and
then you can just own it you can ask you
know go to your
leadership team
as the ceo and say
here's our core values
what do i do to demonstrate that i'm
living up to those core values what do i
do that might indicate that i'm not
living up to those core values and and
once you have that data in your hands
and you're willing to listen which a lot
of old white guys are not willing to
listen
but still you gotta try you gotta you
gotta take this input this hard data
and listen to what the data and the
science are telling you and then you can
make adjustments because that will tell
us michael exactly how far off we are
from from this
ideal defined culture and where we are
now and until we know that we can't
close the gap
so mark take me back a little bit to
your childhood and i'm curious to know
what what you were curious about so you
know as you're going through elementary
middle school you know what
what you mentioned that you were in the
air force before and then you know then
silicon valley and now thinking about
culture so a breadth of experiences and
i'm guessing that culture wasn't
you know the thing that occupied your
mind in in fifth grade
what were you curious about as a kid
two things uh entrepreneurship although
i sure didn't call it that that then i
i i started my own business when i was
eight and
and uh and wow and boy did i get a lot
of crap for that but i
i always knew that that
that there was
more to life than than just going to a
lumber mill which is what my dad did
um and and he was very good at it i mean
he started
pushing a broom uh
you know out of the navy and ended up
owning and managing a lumber mill so it
he was good at it and he was a and he
was a very
um
a decisive leader you knew exactly where
you stood both as a son and as an
employee of my father you knew exactly
where you stood the whole time and
and that probably impacted my view of
leadership quite a bit but um but i
cared about that's all i cared about as
a kid entrepreneurship
and sports that was it i'd like like i
didn't understand even having to go to
school
because you weren't teaching me anything
that was going to make me a better boss
or make my business better
and and so i always had this weird view
of
leadership and culture and work and
and what's really funny now i'm 61 years
old now i'm old
and and now all the stuff that i was
talking about way back then about
um you know taking the time off to go
hunting and fishing and being at your
kids games and all that stuff
that just didn't happen back then well
now we're making that an important part
of life now
we've recalibrated toward that model and
so it's kind of fun to see it all come
full circle
and if i were to ask you for a few words
that you would use to describe yourself
what would those be
well the first one's easy the first one
is mentor i i
love the role it's not a pain gig at all
it's it's
it it never has been
but i i just
especially in the startup world or the
sports world
i just i just love sitting down with
people and asking them you know what
what's working well what
what's keeping you up at night what you
know where are your bigger stressors and
then
and then i i consider myself a solution
junkie which would probably be the
second word or phrase is okay now good
now let's go fix that problem
now that we've been self-aware enough to
actually identify the real problem not
the symptoms
but the problem let's go find a solution
for that
and then um
the third is is a tie i don't know if
it's i've coached baseball for 35 years
and and i also have five kids and five
grandkids so
very much a tie that third word between
dad and grandpa and coach
i love that mark thank you very very
much this was wonderful
i can't wait to read the book and thank
you for sharing this time with me and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
very much thank you michael